welcome to Hannity breaking tonight it
is impeachment eve the circus is coming
to town and we are just now hours away
from the corrupt compromised coward and
congenital liar Adam Schiff show on
Capitol Hill
brought to you by him and his fellow
raging psychotic Democrats and their top
allies in the media mob first know this
is important everything you're going to
see in the next two weeks is rigged this
is a phony show trial there is ZERO due
process none it is yet another
fraudulent hoax conspiracy theory it is
another witch-hunt it is wrought with
rampant I mean rampant putrid hypocrisy
a repulsive double standard by the way
it's all bad for the country but this is
what your Democratic Socialist Party has
become this is who they are this is what
defines them frankly perfectly now
remember tomorrow there's not one single
thing that Democrats have done not one
the past three years not a single thing
they have done except to try to hurt
Donald Trump and we the people that
support him the chop at Walmart proudly
and believe in God they have not lifted
one finger for a better economy to
create any jobs or improve the lives of
you we the American people they have
done absolutely nothing to make this
country safe and secure instead they
have spent the last thirty four months
slander smears besmirched bin of the
president with one coordinated political
hit job after another you know the
routine Russia Russia Russia stormy
stormy s hole impeach impeach
now Ukraine Ukraine same people same
liars same conspiracy theorists the left
frankly they have never accepted the
results of the 2016 election they
thought Trump was going down in flames
we've shown you the tape they were
laughing they were mocking they were
ridiculing they never saw this coming
they were blindsided because in all
reality Democrats and they're willing
accomplices in the mob and the media
they live in this one bubble they have
one agenda one set of opinions
you got the Democrats the mob join
together and what is a sick ugly
degenerate left-wing socialist unholy
alliance and remember this they think
they're smarter than you are than we are
we the American people they think they
know better than us they have utter
contempt and they show it comes out in a
lot of ways for us that are smelly
Walmart shoppers this is not just about
President Trump understand this this is
a serious part they hate everything and
everyone he is representing they hate
the crowds that show up in massive
numbers to support him they refer to us
not only is smelly Walmart people
irredeemable deplorable 'he's angry
bitter americans that cling to God our
Second Amendment our Bibles and religion
guilty as charged
and by the way for years they just
believed the mullah report was their
Holy Grail they thought his findings
would undo the results of the election
they never thought they'd lose they
believed Muller had them they were wrong
no collusion no conspiracy no
obstruction so now they're on to plan B
C and D and they are out for blood make
no mistake about it the next 357 days it
is perfectly obvious now you got to
understand to be a Democrat or part of
the media mob you actually have to be
willing to engage in what is only a
shocking level of raw hypocrisy that
defies all interference of logic
intellect reason and common sense in
other words to be a Democrat or in the
media mob you have to believe that
Russia collusion is such a national
crisis that you're gonna spend two and a
half years investigating a hoax about
Trump and Russia but at the same time
you have to completely ignore Hillary
Clinton's bought and paid for dirty
Russian dossier
that's how bitterly sick twisted and
partisan and hypocritical you need to be
now you have to obsess about phantom
obstruction of justice charges in the
Moller report but then totally ignore
subpoenaed email
that were destroyed deleted with bleach
bid and smashed with with hammers with
devices you have to spend years
obsessing about the horrors of foreign
election interference but then just look
the other way like it doesn't happen
when a DNC operative we now know
actually colluded with the government of
Ukraine in order to smear trump a mana
fort all while bolstering the campaign
Hillary Clinton in 2016 all of this
happened to be a Democrat to be a member
of the media mob you have to demand
fairness and elections but then ignore
how Democratic primary was actually
rigged against Bernie Sanders you have
to drag justice Kavanagh his wife and
young kids through the mud with nothing
but baseless accusations pushed by a
bunch of I believers that don't believe
in due process that don't believe in the
presumption of innocence but then on the
other hand you have to ignore what are
serious rape sexual assault allegations
against lieutenant governor of Virginia
yeah in that case there were no I
believers now to be one of these members
of the mob of the Democratic Party you
have to call every Republican running
for office racist sexist misogynist
homophobic xenophobic blah blah blah but
you're gonna let Ralph KKK Northam off
the hook and by the way I guess now if
you're Democrat you also also have to
accept well first we'll deliver the baby
we'll make the baby comfortable then
we'll let the mother decide if the baby
lives or dies and you have to believe in
open borders and you have to believe
that it's a manufactured crisis 90% of
the heroin coming across our southern
border you have to be willing to
organize a women's March so-called equal
rights and then appoint an anti-semitic
bigot who supports Sharia law to lead
that movement and then say with a
straight face you actually care about
women's rights now to believe in this
repulsive what is really an elitist
holier-than-thou mob you have to
proclaim that the identity of the brave
fake phony non whistleblower
whistleblower hearsay whistleblower that
person must be hidden
that's the here
say complain about the Ukraine call they
that person needs to be respected but
then you have to be totally okay when
CBS fires a news producer for helping
blow the whistle on a story that ABC
News spiked in 2015 about a convicted
pedophile Jeffrey Epstein right
humpty-dumpty right Jeff Zucker and
tonight we're witnessing perhaps the
most shameless hypocrisy of all and the
examples of it because you've got this
corrupt compromised coward for three
years nothing but a congenital liar and
he's by the way light in this case
already Adam Schiff it's gonna kick off
this public witch trial into whether or
not President Trump engaged in a quid
pro quo oh wait a minute we're gonna
change that ex that out on now we'll
call it extortion with the country of
Ukraine and of course he's alleging the
president traded US aid in exchange for
Ukraine's cooperation an election
interference and an investigation the
interesting thing is not one time do you
know in that call not once in that phone
call not a single time
did they ever bring up the issue of
eight not once and then they ignore
completely again only a Democrat can do
this only the mob can do this a corrupt
investigation and to Vice President Joe
Biden and his son Hunter Democrats want
you to forget three things one the
United States has a cooperation
agreement with Ukraine to investigate
crimes election interference is a crime
using taxpayer dollars quid pro quo Joe
you get the billion you fire the
prosecutor investigating my son that
probably is illegal to the president
you're also forgetting this number two
he has a sworn duty to uphold the laws
of the land number three there is clear
evidence of potential crimes when it
comes to interference we know Politico
detailed how the country of Ukraine was
actively working to elect Hillary
Clinton coordinating with a DNC
operative who met with them at the
Ukrainian Embassy in Washington and when
it by the way so also a Ukraine court
confirmed all this but when it comes to
creepy crazy joe 303 300
evidence of a real quid pro quo and him
bragging about it just so happens to be
with the country of Ukraine Joe yes
threaten to withhold one billion dollars
if a Ukrainian prosecutor wasn't fired
within six hours now ask yourself this
question tonight why would a sitting
vice president of the United States care
about some dopey prosecutor in Ukraine
well I think we know the answer probably
had something to do with the fact that
Vice President Biden remember he was
told by the New York Times and others
that this prosecutor was investigating
his son Hunter's not a kid he's like 49
years old now zero experience hunter
Biden he was getting paid millions of
millions of dollars from a Ukrainian and
gas or energy giant Maurice Moe Holdings
at the same time his father was in
charge of US Ukrainian relations for the
Obama administration now hunter must
have offered great experience in Ukraine
no energy no oil none gas none a quid
pro quo Joe wants you to believe there's
zero evidence of any potential
wrongdoing what you're about to see is a
lie take a look look I think that's
every single solitary serious
investigator including your network on
others have looked at this have said
there's absolutely zero basis to the
accusation that I act in any way
inappropriately or that my son did this
is all about Trump trying to create a
diversion what Joe Biden said right
there is a lie he's the only corrupt
player that we know of you current with
Ukraine so he would prefer you don't
believe his own bragging video evidence
and don't believe that zero experience
hunter Biden's multi-million dollar
payday with Ukraine actually happen now
we've detailed thanks to Greg Jarrett
that the Biden's especially Joe probably
is in real legal trouble if we had equal
application of our laws in this country
and equal
justice under the law because we have a
law called the Foreign Corrupt Practices
Act where it is illegal Joe for a u.s.
person to coerce or influence a foreign
nation into taking action fire the
prosecutor that might financially
benefit that person his family hunter or
business and then we have bribery laws
where it is illegal to offer or promise
anything of value a billion dollars for
of official for a public official to
influence an official act fire the
prosecutor and by the way giving
offering promising anything of value to
a public official in exchange for an
official act is a violation of the
gratuity statute that's also a felony
and we have the Hobbs Act a threat to a
foreign official in order to obtain an
official benefit affecting interstate
foreign commerce would constitute
something called extortion Democrats
tonight are hoping you we the American
people smelly Walmart Trump supporters
ignore what are inescapable truths about
Biden corruption instead what they want
you to believe is that Donald Trump is
guilty of the quid pro quo simply
because of the opinions of people that
share their hatred of Donald Trump deep
state bureaucrats about a phone call and
they're biased interpretation of a call
for which the transcript is now totally
public for all to see their
interpretation is dead wrong there's
never any mention of any financial
anything in that phone call and get this
we have a New York Post articles written
by Jonathan Tobin he brings up a really
good point quote how can the house
examine this matter without probing
Trump's motivation for requesting
Ukraine investigate the violence don't
but don't expect to see hunter or Joe
Biden testify the cowardly corrupt
compromise congenital liar shift he
won't allow it
this is not a real investigation this is
a political circus there's no due
process this is a show trial they have
pre-selected pre interviewed if you will
the people that they want to trot out
first that they think will most make
their case
because they have a predetermined
outcome and we know that chip is already
pre interviewed his favorite witnesses
behind closed door and will now only
allow his favorites to testify and
cherry-pick the witnesses in fact this
compromise congenital liar won't even
allow the non whistleblower
whistleblower to take the stand when he
first said that he would take the stand